be fresh as hell loaded  this and that thing I say baby round and  round round and round  shoddy let me hear you say my name  hey I'm rich  plus I'm super lit  now she want to make me all her man  so we confront here again this this  theme of inner turmoil right round and  round you can hear the pain in his voice  but then he says shoddy let me hear you  say my name so this is ultimately what  young boy wants from the world that's  what all young boys want from the world  to be acknowledged right to be known to  feel his existence validated by the  recognition of others it's a natural  desire it's a common Pursuit But  ultimately empty and that's where I  think this will lead in the conclusion  to this epic I think it's leading  maybe the tragedy